all right we have a new generation of
investors
uh millennial investors gen z investors
and
uh robin hood is part of this phenomenon
robin hood
i think has over 10 million members uh
nick can check that for me and dump it
into the uh
dump it into the chat room and then on
and that has created this
incredible um wall street
bets kind of subreddit phenomenon of
people
essentially looking at buying stocks as
i would say
not just for uh their future
and uh for wealth creation but maybe as
a pastime
uh and there are a number of these meme
stocks like nikola
which uh and the recently bankrupt hurts
which had got dragged into this
massively popular and uh un
bizarre um race where nicola became
worth 30 billion dollars without having
a product in market um
they make you know trucks that are
electric trucks and i guess we'll
compete with tesla's semi
and on top of that hertz
which file for bankruptcy kept going up
even though people
know that the likely scenario is that
the equity gets wiped
out so i guess
the question here is how much of an
impact this is making on the market
um oh and then just adding to this the
barstool sports founder dave
portnoy who i want to get on the pod
because he's just endlessly fascinating
uh i know i'm late to the party and
following him but his periscope had over
a hundred thousand
views today and he's doing
daveydaytrader
and saying i guess the meme is stonks
only go up
another way of saying stocks only go up
and then today
the dow plummeted so uh i don't know
what this crazy behavior means
but any thoughts on it to um
um i guess the first thing i would say
is everybody should check out wall
street that's the subreddit it is
hilarious the memes are
tremendous um i think you have a lot of
people
with more time on their hands than they
know what to do with right now
um not spending as much money as they
might
as we're all kind of confined to our
apartments ah that's a good theory
so yeah i mean my hope is people that
don't know what they're doing
um hopefully just play with fun money i
started playing high stakes poker when i
was 15 or 16 so i'm in no position to
call anyone else
but yeah i mean the reformed finance
major and me has to say you know
build your emergency fund max out your
ira
throw the rest on wealth running some
index funds i know you'll like that
wealth front plug jason
yeah index funds are the way to build
long-term wealth and and to ride out
these storms and if you want to gamble
by all means go ahead and gamble
um and learn how to trade stocks but do
it with the amount of money you can
afford
to lose i like you as a gambler a
high-stakes poker player
um and i don't wait i don't do sports
betting but i know a lot of people who
do
i find that like you don't have any
control of the outcome generally
speaking
uh i know some people think they can
handicap really well um
i don't know if that's proven to be true
that often uh but i do feel like this is
positive because they're actually
learning a lot about how the stock
market works and yeah if you bet on a
bankrupt company or you bet on a company
whose products not in market you're
going to learn a big lesson because
nikola in all likelihood in my mind is
not going to be worth 30 billion dollars
next year or the year after or for the
next 10 years i know i would be
very surprised if their party product
even makes it to market i don't know
what a public
why there's a public company for a
product that's not even a market yet
they did some reverse merger
any thoughts lolita i mean
if you're a gambler and that's your
thing that's your decision
i think that and in terms of it the
implications of these gamblers
uh gambling in the market i i think
there are bigger
fish that will move the needle uh
and and not these uh millennials on on
robin hood i definitely think the covet
impacts
of how we're driving supply chains and
moving products around and
living and selling i think those have
more impacts on the market than
the robin hood investors